in great baking as with all cooking
sometimes less is more
these dishes look and taste spectacular
when they're done well
and it doesn't come any simpler or more
stylish than my next dish wonderful
baked cheesecake for me food always has
to be impressive but when it comes to
desserts often you see Sponge sugar or
wild decorations remember simple is
always the most impressive this
cheesecake is so straightforward yet so
delicious
well cream cheese leave it out of the
fridge for five or ten minutes go nice
and soft trust me your arms will be
thanking you
sugar in this cheesecake is a New York
cheesecake because it's baked so there's
no base start creaming the cheese and
the sugar
spending the amount of time I do in the
states if there's one thing they know
how to do out there is the most amazing
impressive cheesecake Rich delicious but
so simple work the bowl
lift the ball to your advantage
really whisk
whisk whisk whisk
lovely
creamy now
get your eggs
add the extra mixture bit by bit doing
it this way it's more efficient hey
you're incorporating a lot of Air B the
mixture doesn't separate
Blaster of your egg
of course you can use electric mixer but
if I go to the gym we can just make a
cheesecake a day
cheesecake a day
keep the Bingo Wings away
now a couple tablespoons of flour
give it a whisk stop something going
Lumpy
now I want to scent that cheesecake
I've got the freshness zest the lemon in
there I want to sort of tart it up even
more fold in some fresh raspberries
sort of just mix them through be careful
to crush them
then grease a cake tin with butter this
will ensure your cheesecake slides out
beautifully
get your mix
let that fall in
now take your cake tin and just
tap it
mixture hits the bottom of the cake tin
The Raspberries rise and you've got
raspberries at the top the middle and
the bottom it also stops all those
little pockets of air trapping
underneath the mixture and the cake tin
there's no holes
in the cheesecake now into the oven 180
degrees for 35 to 40 minutes
[Music]
hmm
slightly soufflaid up
pull off
[Music]
that's the color I wanted on top
and look at it
it's one of the simplest yet the most
stylish cheesecakes anywhere
beautiful
[Music]
to keep old dishes fresh and exciting
it's great to get spicy
my next recipe is a time-honored British
classic but with addition of spices it's
given a new lease of Life fragrant spice
rice pudding I love cooking with spices
but you don't have to just cook Savory
dishes using aromatics and spices across
desserts takes your puddings to a
completely different level
[Music]
first off as spices this is a fresh
vanilla pot fragrant and packed full of
flavor use the back of the knife and
flatten it that removes all those little
seeds off the skin of the vanilla pod
take your knife slice down the middle
and then when you open that up the smell
is incredible
take the tip of the knife and you scrape
inside and look
all those seeds dying to come out that
is incredible there are thousands of
seeds still ingrained to the Pod so put
them in to the casserole cardamom
powerful spicy say two little pods place
your knife on top
and lightly crack them cracking the
cardamom pods helps release all the
amazing flavor cloves
because of that kind of aniseed flavor
with a lot of depth
one two three cinnamon stick
snap and in
just smelling that level of fragrance
you can imagine what the rice pudding is
going to taste of turn on the heat
lightly toast those spices just a couple
of seconds and what's going to happen is
just going to sort of enhance those
spices in a way that it just draws out
an even more powerful fragrance coconut
milk in
sugar two tablespoons
milk
and then a couple of tablespoons of
cream
bring it slowly to the boil to allow the
flavors to infuse and this rice pudding
reminds me of my time in India where I
got really into that chai tea fragrance
because it was just so delicious
and so comforting
take a lime
in
the lime just cuts through the richness
of the coconut gives it that nice little
bit of acidity goes fantastically well
with the cinnamon and that fresh vanilla
nice have a taste
now let's come up to the boil give it a
nice little clean around the outside
and in with the rice
use 200 grams of pudding rice don't wash
it beforehand because the starch helps
thicken the rice pudding in the oven
and just turn that down to a light
simmer and the pudding rice starts to
open up and it absorbs all that coconut
vanilla
cardamom clove and cinnamon bring up to
the ball gently and cook it out three to
five minutes
boiling it rapidly the rice opens up and
it goes into mush so we want to keep
that nice texture of that sort of
fragrant rice pudding on a gentle simmer
next a little luxury
I'm going to show you how I take this
simple delicious aromatic rice pudding
to a completely different level here's
what I do take two egg yolks separate
them
now give that a really nice whisk
two nice tablespoons of mascarpone
cheese
whisk that into the egg yolks
so it's nice and smooth
it's almost like finishing the rice
pudding in a delicious custard turn off
the gas add that
into the rice pudding what happens it
starts to enrich and really thicken this
rice pudding and takes it to a
completely different level
the rice is still not cooked started to
go nice and soft you can just see how
it's opening up
but look it's like Rich aromatic lava
bubbling away
finally great more citrus zest the lime
on top
roasted caramelized lime zest on top of
a rice pudding
is phenomenal
then put it in the oven for 15 minutes
at 200 degrees to finish cooking the
rice and develop the intensely aromatic
flavors
look at that
an incredibly fragrant rice pudding how
beautiful does that look
spices are a brilliant way of helping
classic dishes come alive
I'll guarantee you'll never ever have
had a rice pudding like this before
next recipe is a proper British classic
that's super simple to cook and costs
next to nothing a delicious apple
crumble
crumbles are the perfect way to use
fruit when it's in season there's lots
of it about it's nice and cheap but most
importantly the fruits at its absolute
best
foreign
make a really nice light caramel pan on
nice and low great two apples
[Music]
and this helps to almost sort of pure
the Apple so much quicker there's a lot
of flavor in the skin so don't worry
about peeling the fruit whether it's
pears plums peaches flavors in the skin
[Music]
start the camera a couple of tablespoons
of sugar the sugar helps to get rid of
the tartness in the Apple a touch
Cinema that starts to make it a little
spicy open up your vanilla just scrape
out all those seeds now this just makes
it light and fragrant all those seeds in
to the Sugar We're making caramel be
patient and always swirl the dish
instead of stirring it
when the sugar goes Brown add the Apple
starts to sort of cool down the caramel
but it gives it a really nice sort of
caramelized puree apples almost
disintegrating
smells incredible turn the gas down
slice up two apples it's a crumble
That's Got No Frills straight forward no
faffing around no peeling on the skin I
want them to sort of stand out from the
camera
apples in
now those nice thick chunks of Apple
sort of almost bedding itself into the
puree
dried cranberries gives it that nice
sort of shock in the texture
sweet
and chewy I want it to sort of taste
zesty spicy so sit the lemon zest on top
of your apples and cranberry fresh lemon
juice over and that just gives that
extra acidic kick takes the Cranberries
the apples the caramel and the cinnamon
to another level turn the gas off
that says let's concentrate on the
crumble flowering
a couple of tablespoons of Demerara
sugar sugar helps to get the topping
nice and crispy butter in
give that a nice little rub what we're
looking for is like a
breadcrumb mixture lightly season it
with a touch of cinnamon
and the dinner sugar sort of helps to
get a nice fine crumble mix and it stops
the butter from sort of melting in that
flour so that's the basic crumble mix
but I'm not finished yet muesli
two-thirds crumble
one-third muesli mix that in if you
haven't got muesli then crunchy granola
works brilliantly too lovely
now start off in the center
work your way around
I want the crispiness on the top
the puree on the bottom of the caramel
and then the texture in the center a
good tip
and the gas back on I want it bubbling
before it goes in the oven because then
you just got to cook the top so as soon
as you see that caramel starting to
Bubble down the side in she goes let's
go
all right
bake it 200 degrees Celsius for 12 to 14
minutes until golden brown
smells amazing
[Music]
still bubbling
and look at it a delicious but very
simple crumble with apples at their
absolute best beautiful
[Music]
foreign